people were super into taking selfies
with their thumbs in my eyes
I remember getting a little bit of an
eye infection Pedro Pascal shares the
bizarre Game of Thrones fan Obsession
that gave him an eye infection I win
with the grossest death don't I I mean
it's the most disgusting anyway I
remember early because of Game of
Thrones and the way that my character
died people were super into taking
selfies with their thumbs in my eyes
oh
Pedro had his reasons for allowing the
odd fan behavior and why it had to come
to a screeching halt at first I was um I
was so kind of earnest and and happy
about the success of the character in
the show and I uh would let them in New
York and
um you would let them go like all places
and uh and I remember getting a little
bit of an eye infection he opened up
about the moment on an episode of the
Hollywood reporters actors round table
last week and fans have become obsessed
with Pedro since his roles in the
Mandalorian and The Last of Us
it's okay baby girl
don't you
[Music]
head no he's even been crowned the
internet's daddy you Google your name
and daddy 1.5 million things come up
he's daddy yep I am your coolest lady
Daddy I
fear I may have daddied us a little too
close to the sun he just daddy does too
hard I think I did you can never I am
having fun with it
um I think that it it uh it it seems a
little role related I think there was a
period where
um uh the Mandalorian is very Daddy to
baby grogu
um Joel is very uh Daddy to Ellie
um these are daddy Parts yeah that's
what it is are you a daddy I'm not a
daddy I'm not gonna be a daddy foreign
[Music]